thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here
Ali is with us in Austin Texas hey Ally
how are you hey Dave how's your day
better than I deserve what about you um
what could be a little better I have a
question for you since I was 18 my
father and I have had issues with my
stepmother opening about credit cards in
rnase since then I've paid about $10,000
off in her debt and one others well my
dad is the sole source of income for the
family and he had over 50 grand in his
name so why would you allow anyone to
steal your identity and then you pay the
bill well she she's had control of it
while I was in high school and
everything no she knows I doubt about it
no she doesn't it's still illegal yes
yes it is definitely illegal I've got
completely why would you pay the bill
for my dad why how is it helping your
dad to support a criminal right well see
okay so recently I had another one pop
up and from what these people are saying
is that it was opened up in 2005 did you
open it no I did not then you don't know
it okay yes well I have a question in
reference through the limits of a
limitation statute there is no debt
there is no statute of limitations on a
debt that you don't oh yes well I was
trying to keep this like as civil as
possible not civil to support a bank
robber Hey the ladies are freaking thief
agreed okay at what point are you guys
gonna quit this I mean you guys are like
the whole family protecting drunk mom
this is so codependent it's unbelievable
are you hearing yourself
oh now trust me I've went around and
around for years and you know my dad's
my best friend and anything I can do to
help him I try to we think you're
helping him I think I'm helping inside
like in money-wise yes he recently found
another 15 grams that he's going to have
to pay and they
no he does not for me mean what's he
gonna stop I don't know what are we
gonna deal with this woman you want to
help your dad help him deal with this
woman well and and that's my plan now
I've already talked because I am in law
enforcement I've talked to one of my
investigators and they said the best
thing to do is to file a fraud report
yes I understand that but I was calling
in reference for my dad from this card
that the last payment was made it was in
2006 and in state of Texas for those
Texas remedies and practices I think it
was it says that say Texas it's four
years and no it's not no it's not it's
not there's no years involved there is
no statute of limitations on a debt you
do not owe identity theft you do not owe
Ally you're in law enforcement if
someone steals someone's checkbook and
signs their checks and that bank comes
back after the person they can't collect
on it because the checks were
fraudulently signed isn't that correct
oh yeah yes okay they can't collect on
this debt the debt is fraud based just
because you know the crook doesn't mean
it's not a criminal I know we're just
trying to keep it civil it's not civil
honey it's codependent I'm serious you
guys have got to deal with this she's
not gonna stop have you not figured that
out don't you think like every time your
dad cleans this crap up she does it
again well what is your recommendation
that's my recommendation is to file a
fraud report okay just in reference to
the one because I know my dad isn't
gonna go in there and do that
okay well that's your dad's problem you
can't make your dad behave but um he's
you know he's acting like this is gonna
go away he's acting like his wife is on
cocaine and he's acting like she doesn't
have a problem
you see it every day in your world don't
you oh yeah people that close their eyes
and put their hands over their ears and
go oh this isn't really
happening and so that that's I'm not
trying to be mean to her or mean to you
or create problems for you you've
already got problems but I don't think
the statute of limitations applies you
can check with a lawyer but I'm pretty
sure it doesn't apply in a fraud
situation because in a fraud situation
the debt is declared completely invalid
yeah
and let me just tell you here's the sad
truth they probably will not criminally
pursue her but I would file a police
report a fraud police report on this and
tell the truth that you know who the
criminal is and then I would get in
touch with the fraud and fraud victim
division of that particular credit-card
company and I would say listen here's
the police report I just discovered this
apparently it was my stepmother I'm not
sure can't prove that but I can't prove
that but I can prove it wasn't me you do
not have my signature on file and you
need to clear this file from my name
because you don't have me it's identity
theft good luck on finding the crook
things actly and you got oh and then
they're going to want 62 different
affidavits filled out and other things
and you fill them all out and it gets
out of your name you need to clean up
your name Ally but really for this
lady's sake somebody needs to deal with
her he's mentally ill I I agree I agree
I agree completely
somebody needs to love her enough to
help her yeah yeah huh the kids like
that all history don't cover for anymore
you got to love her enough to help her
and yeah maybe that's a good way to help
your dad is give him the strength to
deal with something that he's a good man
and he just doesn't have the strength to
deal with this and it's not he and well
I love her it's not loving her you're
not loving your wife while you're
standing there watching her destroy you
and destroy her own life and be a crook
that is not loving someone that's just
being a wuss it's not love it's being a
coward
and I don't mean that - I'm not trying
to be mean to you or to him I'm just
trying to say real clearly that you guys
need to not ever say the word love in
regard to this situation anymore because
there's 90 love here until you help this
lady
that's when there's love open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five I got to tell you this
identity-theft thing drives me bananas
it's one thing for some bozo in some
Eastern Bloc country to hat targets
files or whoever and get your stuff and
then sell those numbers off and you get
your identity you get your identity
stolen that's one thing I get that
there's crooks everywhere there's
mobsters everywhere I get the whole
thing I understand it's just part of
life today you really aren't safe I
understand that but when your own dadgum
family does it select financial incest
it's unbelievable it's so gross it just
when I get all redneck I just want to
smack somebody I mean I cannot believe
someone you know I run in these people
all the time who stole their elderly
parents identity and ran up debt in some
eighty seven year olds name because
they're too freakin lazy to get a job
and buy their own car I run up people
outrunning people all the time like this
poor lady ally I'm just talking to bless
her sweetheart she and her dad they're
just nice as they can be and I'm glad
we've got nice people in law enforcement
that's a good thing we need them there
but you know what what kind of what kind
of monster is this woman that just keep
it takes a seventeen-year-old Ally and
starts running up debt in a teenager in
her house I mean it's just unbelievable
man let me just tell you let me help you
with this if you're signing someone
else's name to a document and you don't
have a power of attorney you just
committed fraud you're a criminal
well I just might I didn't know you're a
freakin criminal you do not sign someone
else's name to a document period unless
you have a power of attorney you do not
have rights to do that because you know
them because you sired them or because
you're in their bloodline
or because God helped them they married
you you're a freaking crook when you
steal money and when you steal money
using your own kids your own family's
name
you just get a special kind of gross
stamped on your forehead unbelievable
stop it people listen if you're facing
this stuff or even if you're not you
need to go to Xandar insurance.com
you need to get that identity theft
protection in place they assign a
counselor to you to take care all this
if it happens to you a caseworker that's
why I've got it on me my kids and every
one of my employees
this stuff's rampant